[MUSIC PLAYING]
STANLEY Y SHAW: Every day,
millions of data points
are being generated about your health.
What if all this data could be combined
and shared with health care teams
to improve patient care?
The reality is that health care is
very different from retail or banking
or travel.
And digital transformation in health
care need people who are bilingual,
fluent in the powerful
new digital tools that
are emerging, but also in the culture
and workflows of real-life medicine.
We have to take a health
care-centered view of tech disruption.
In digital health, you explore
the opportunities and caveats
related to the widespread adoption
of digital tools in health care.
You'll acquire new frameworks to
help you navigate stakeholder needs,
create value, foster
trust and engagement,
demonstrate improved outcomes,
and develop sustainable business
models, and all of this in the unique
context of the health care ecosystem.
SEAN DUFFY: I really think
we're the first inning of what's
possible in digital health.
And we'll go on a journey
over the next decade, where
more and more and more
of clinical services
will be pushed either into the pocket,
into the home, or into the cloud.
KATHERINE CHOU: But ultimately,
people are expecting for that data
to be used for the purposes of
improving their health care outcomes.
MARCUS OSBORNE: The most
important thing that we can do
is how we can create a path
forward to leverage data
to really help people
get insights that can
help them better engage
in their health and better
understand what's going on right now.
STANLEY Y SHAW: This
program is for anyone
who wants to learn more about leading
digital-enabled initiatives in health
care.
The future of health care is digital.
[MUSIC PLAYING]